But let's presume you really need a raster image
because some things just can't be represented well by a
vector drawing. This is a 21 megapixel photo of my
cat. Obviously, you probably really don't need that resolution pushed
down to a mobile device if I'm just writing
a blog post about my cat. This is a 4
megabyte image after all. So what should we do with
this image to deliver it to different devices? Your first
option is to kind of cheat. You can always
deliver a high resolution but low quality encoding
everywhere. That is, give this same image to
all devices. That's a higher resolution, a 2x
image for example. But lower the quality in
the jpeg encoder to 20 rather than 90.
This typically can result in a 2X image
that will look better than an uncompressed 1X image.
And you'll notice at the same time, it actually has
a smaller file size. Using this technique will work well
in many cases. But it does come at a cost.
The browser also needs to spend some time decompressing the
image, and on a 1x device, it needs to scale
the image by 50% to fit it into the available
pixels. You can also start to see some color [INAUDIBLE]
and some gradients using this approach. Sure, lower pixel count
devices will get a bigger image than they need But not too much more data since
it's low quality. In higher pixel count devices,
we'll get the right size. Although they will get
a slightly lower quality image than they would
normally want. This option isn't great, but it's definitely
better than only serving low pixel count art.
Or serving only high pixel count to all devices.